APPEARING BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
LET'S BRING IN FORMER TRUMP
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER AND
FORMER AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED
NATIONS UNDER GEORGE W. BUSH
AMBASSADOR BOLTON.
DO YOU THINK MIKE PENCE WOULD
TESTIFY IF ASKED TO DO SO IS
THIS.
>> I THINK IT DEPENDS ON THE IS
IRKSS.
AND THERE ARE WAYS DO THIS AND
WAYS NOT TO DO IT.
IF THEY WANT NOT A DEPOSITION,
NOT RAISING HIS RIGHT HAND, BUT
A CONVERSATION WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT, NOT IN PUBLIC VIEW,
THAT MAY BE A DIFFERENT STORY.
IT DEPENDS ON WHETHER THE
COMMITTEE WANTS INFORMATION OR
PUBLICITY.
>> AND SPEAKING OF TESTIFYING,
YOU TWEETED ABOUT LIZ CHENEY'S
LOSS.
YOU SAID THAT HER LOSS, QUOTE, I
DID MINUTISHES THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO
CRITICISM THAT WENT YOUR WAY
FROM JOHN DEAN.
HE SAID, QUOTE -- HAD YOU ACTED,
SPEAKINGED A YOU ACTED
AND TESTIFIED IN THE FIRST
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL, YOU MIGHT
HAVE PERSUADED THEM TO REMOVE
HIM AND WE'LL BE DONE.
MOVING PASTINSULT, IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS THE SUBSTANCE.
>> IF WOULD HAVE MADE NO
DIFFERENCE.
THE PEOPLE THAT LED THE
IMPEACHMENT MADE THE SITUATION
WORSE.
THEY MADE NO EFFORT WHATEVER TO
BROADEN THE SUPPORT FOR THE
IMPEACHMENT IN MANY, MANY WAYS.
IT WOULD TAKE A LONG TIME TO
DESCRIBE.
THEY WERE SATISFIED THAT TRUMP
HAD BEEN IMPEACHED.
NANCY PELOSI SAYS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN HE WILL ALWAYS BE
IMPEACHED.
AND THEY FAILED TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT HE WAS GOING TO BE
ACQUITTED BY THE SENATE.
SO THE RESULT IS THAT THEY
THOUGHT THAT -- THEY SURELY
DIDN'T THINK THAT THEY COULD
REMOVE HIM FROM OFFICE, BUT THEY
THOUGHT THAT IMPEACHMENT WOULD
CONSTRAIN OR DETER HIM FROM
FURTHER CONDUCT.
BUT THE MALPRACTICE FELT THAT HE
WAS EMBOLDENED.
AND THAT WOULDN'T BE ALLEVIATED
BY ME OR ANYBODY ELSE.
IT WAS A FUNDAMENTAL POLITICAL
FLAW IN THE WAY THAT THEY WENT
ABOUT IT.
>> AND YOU REFERRED TO RUDY
GIULIANI AS A HAND GRENADE I
BELIEVE DURING THE WHOLE UKRAINE
SCANDAL THAT LED TO THE FIRST
IMPEACHMENT.
HE IS TESTIFYING BEFORE A GRAND
JURY, HE IS A TARGET OF THE
FULTON COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S CRIMINAL PROBE INTO
THE SCHEME TO OVERTURN GEORGIA'S
ELECTORAL VOTES.
YOU'VE BEEN IN THE TRUMP ORBIT.
DO YOU THINK THAT GIULIANI WOULD
BE WILLING TO GO TO PRISON TO
PROTECT DONALD TRUMP GIVEN THE
FACT THAT HE COULD NOT BE
PARDONED BY HIM AT LEAST NOT FOR
A WHILE?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THAT HE
WANTS TO GO TO PRISON, THAT IS
FOR SURE.
MY GUESS IS THAT HIS ATTORNEY
SAID AFTER THE TESTIMONY TODAY
ABOUT SIX HOURS WORTH THAT HE
WASN'T GOING TO COMMENT ON IT,
WHICH IS INTERESTING.
BUT I SUSPECT THAT IT WAS SIX
HOURS OF TAKING THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT.
>> LET'S TURN TO IRAN.
FOLLOWING A STRING OF PLANNED OR
ACTUAL ATTACKS ON AMERICANS
OUTSPOKEN AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT
OF IRAN, INCLUDING AN
ASSASSINATION PLOT TARGETING
YOU, AN ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT ON
IRANIAN AMERICAN JOURNALIST WHO
WE'VE HAD ON THE SHOW, AND OF
COURSE LAST WEEK'S HORRIFIC
STABBING ATTACK ON SALMAN
RUSHDIE, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
EVIDENCE EXISTS OUT THERE, BUT
WHAT DO YOUR NATIONAL SECURITY
INSTINCTS TELL YOU ARE ALL OF
THESE IRAN-RELATED THREATS AND
ATTACKS IN SUCH A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME, DO YOU THINK THAT THEY
ARE RELATED?
>> WELSH I THINK THAT WHAT YOU
CAN CONCLUDE FROM ALL THESE, AND
MORE THAT HAVE NOT BEEN REPORTED
AND STILL SUBJECT TO BEING
WATCHED AND THE REST OF IT, THAT
THE GOVERNMENT OF IRAN FEELS NO
DANGER FROM THE UNITED STATES.
THEY THINK THAT THEY CAN ACT
WITH IMPUNITY, EVEN AS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ON ITS KNEES
TRYING TO GET BACK INTO THE 2015
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
THEY THINK THAT THEY CAN CARRY
OUT WHAT IN EFFECT IS AN ACT OF
WAR AGAINST TRYING TO KILL
CITIZENS OF THE UNITED STATES ON
AMERICAN SOIL.
I'M NOT SURE THERE IS RESIDENT
FOR THIS.
THIS IS NOT JUST STATE SHOP OR
SHIP OF TERRORISM.
THIS IS STATE TERRORISM OF AN
UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT
BIDEN SHOULD BE DOING?
THE THREAT WAS DIRECTIONALLY
AGAINST YOU, THE RUSHDIE THREAT
WAS INCITED BY IRAN AND
REDECLARED THE FATWA JUST DAYS
BEFORE THE ATTACK.
THERE OBVIOUSLY -- THEY ARE
DOING IT ON PURPOSE.
WHAT SHOULD BIDEN DO?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT THEY HAVE
TO DO MORE THAN ISSUE STATEMENTS
SAYING THAT AN ATTACK ON
AMERICAN WILL BE MET WITH
REPRISAL.
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY INSUFFICIENT
DETERRENCE AND IT MEANS WAITING
UNTIL SOMEBODY IS DISPATCHED.
SALMAN RUSHDIE WAS GRIEVOUSLY
WOUNDED.
IT IS A MIRACLE HE IS ALIVE.
SO IF WE HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL THE
REVOLUTIONARY GUARDS OR THEIR
AGENTS ACTUALLY KILL SOMEBODY
BEFORE WE DO ANYTHING, THEN I
THINK THE IRANIANS WILL CONTINUE
TO BE ENCOURAGED.
I THINK THAT YOU HAVE TO SAY
WE'RE WALKING AWAY, YOU ARE AN
UNCIVILIZED GOVERNMENT AND YOU
ARE NOT WORTH YOUR WORD ON
ANYTHING AND WE'LL TAKE STEPS TO
PROTECT AMERICANS AND WIDER
WORLD AGAINST THE WORLD.
NOT THE NUCLEAR ISSUE HE